with just 20 days to go before the Iowa
caucuses the Democrats faced off last
night in Des Moines Iowa and everybody
lost that's right nobody won not Biden
not Bernie not Warren not Pete not the
voters not the viewers every candidate
did terribly we will examine why and how
that train wreck happened and what it
means for 2020 then House Democrats
refused to condemn Iran for attacking us
Vince Vaughn gets cancelled for shaking
hands with the president and Mike
Bloomberg goes full boomer all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
you have to know that I love you you my
faithful listener I love you so much
that I sat through every single minute
of that tedious awful boring creepy
terrible terrible terrible debate for
you so that I could bring you the
moments we were only watching for one
reason those few of you who did watch
and me we were watching for one reason
and that was to see fireworks between
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren in
recent days just the past three days or
so
Warren leaked a story to CNN that Bernie
Sanders during a 20-18 meeting told her
that a woman can't win the White House
in 2020 Bernie's camp denied this then
Warren's camp corroborated this I mean
they didn't really corroborate it they
just backed her up and said yeah I heard
her I heard him say this I was in the
meeting and then Elizabeth Warren said
it happened to Elizabeth Warren was
asked about this by reporters she said
yeah he thought that a woman couldn't
win I thought a woman could win but
anyway we're moving on now
the fact that the Warren campaign leaked
this to CNN is important because CNN was
hosting the debate so that's what we
were all tuning in for I was just see
finally these candidates are gonna take
the gloves off Warren and Sanders have
had this kind of friendly relationship
so far they've been teaming up to go
after the other candidates now they're
gonna go after one another right wrong
CNN asks the question they finally bring
it up first the question goes to Bernie
Sanders Bernie did you say this thing in
2018 Bernie Sanders gives an unequivocal
no way CNN reported yesterday that and
senator Sanders senator Warren confirmed
in a statement that in 2018 you told her
that you did not believe that a woman
could win the election why did you say
that well as a matter of fact I didn't
say oh and I don't want to waste a whole
lot of time on this this is what Donald
Trump and maybe some of the media want
anybody knows me knows that it's
incomprehensible that I would think that
a woman
could not be President to the United
States go to youtube today there's some
video of the of me 30 years ago talking
about how a woman could become president
of the United States in 2015 I deferred
in fact the Senate Awards was a movement
to draft Senator Warren to run for
president and you know what I said stay
back
senator Warren decided not to run an IV
I did run afterwards Hillary Clinton won
the popular vote by three million votes
how could anybody in a million years not
believe that a woman could become
president of the United States and let
me be very clear if any of the women on
this stage or any of the men on this
stage win the nomination I hope that's
not the case I hope it's me but if they
do I will do everything in my power to
make sure that they are elected in order
to defeat the most dangerous president
in the history of our country all right
this is what I would expect this answer
is exactly what I would expect I never
believed Elizabeth Warren's story it
just doesn't make any sense why because
Bernie Sanders would have to be insane
to make that comment to one of his
competitors and Bernie might be many
things he might be a wild ideologue he
might be an old communist codger but
he's not insane there is actually a sort
of internal logic to his political
ideology he has an insane ideology right
every has an ideology that one should
not hold but he's not a political maniac
okay the guy's been able to stay in
office for a very long time it would be
so profoundly politically foolish to
make that sort of comment
second of all Bernie is not in any way a
sexist there's just no evidence of it
everywhere you could say a lot of things
about the guy but there's no evidence
that that he would even hold that view
that a woman couldn't become president
the guy's a radical he's been a radical
for a long time I'm not surprised he
said in the 80s that a woman could
become president
third Elizabeth Warren is one of the
most notorious liars in the country so
if I got to choose who's being honest
here the woman who
lied about her native-american ancestry
lied about where her kids went to school
lied about getting fired for being
pregnant or Bernie Sanders who's an old
coot but is pretty consistent I'm gonna
go with Bernie Sanders listen to have
CNN they phrase the question they said
why did you say that to burnt to
Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth Warren is
alleging that you said that a woman
can't become president you're saying you
never said that why did you say that and
then it gets so much worse when CNN
turns the question to Elizabeth Warren
we'll get to that in a second first I
gotta thank our friends over at AB AB
sleep I know that we got a lot of
insomniacs out there in the audience I I
know my friend Andrew Klavan insomniac
he hasn't slept for probably thirty
forty years and I know that's for many
of you if you've tried everything with
little success it is time for you to try
AB what is AB AB sleep is a wearable
solution that fits over the forehead and
gently and precisely cools the forehead
to reduce those racing thoughts to allow
people who are suffering from sleep
lessness to drift more comfortably into
deeper and more restorative sleep it's
so simple and yet it's medically backed
up AB is clinically validated four out
of five users report falling asleep
faster and improving overall sleep
quality the science is simple the
science is that when your mind is racing
for insomnia acts when you put this kind
of cooling mask over your forehead it
reduces those racing thoughts the minds
normal way of dealing with stress and
challenge is to be on guard and to be
vigilant you're going to be really
aroused and and and ready to go and so
to get a good night's sleep you've got
to reverse that ebbs cooling calming
nature is designed to counteract the way
that the mind and body reacts to
stressful situations
it's it's a really really innovative
solution if you've tried everything to
get to sleep you got to try this this is
clinically backed have the energy to do
the things that you love again by
getting the sleep that you need ABS
natural solution has no morning side
effects and allows you to get back to
your peak performance I wore it just
last night and now I'm all ready and
raring to go to do this show and it's
very early here on me on the
westcoast so you got to try this thing
out our listeners can now try ab
risk-free for 60 nights to confirm it's
the solution you've been looking for
there's no reason not to try it try
abdominals that's t ry e BB comm slash
anoles try AB comm slash Noel's order it
today to get the sleep you need and
deserve CNN from the beginning is is
accepting the premise that Elizabeth
Warren is telling the truth which is
always a bad premise to accept you
should never assume that Elizabeth
Warren is ever telling the truth they
asked Bernie why did you say this Bernie
says I never said this so then they
turned to Elizabeth Warren and they
asked her I kid you not
why how did you feel when Bernie Sanders
said this to you senator Sanders you're
saying that you never told senator
Warren that a woman could not win the
election that is correct senator Warren
what did you think when senator Sanders
told you a woman could not win the
election I just agreed bernie is my
friend and I am not here to try to fight
with Bernie okay that she's lying right
you get this is how you can tell she's
lying here's the proof she evaded the
question when it was posed to her like
that she evaded the question how did you
feel when he said this she goes I
disagreed but I'm not here to fight with
Bernie of course you're here to fight
with Bernie what are you talking about
you're at a presidential debate by the
way you leaked this to CNN who's hosting
the debate now if it were a true claim
that you were making she would have
leaked it to CNN she would have brought
it up at the debate if she didn't bring
it up the moderator would have brought
it up she would have pounced on him but
it isn't true and she doesn't want to
have to defend it so she evades the
question because the real reason she
leaked it is she just once this kind of
muck out there she just wants this
insinuation that Bernie Sanders is a
sexist and a chauvinist and a misogynist
but she doesn't want to have to defend
it cuz she's got no evidence for it just
like she's got no evidence that she's
Native American even though she claimed
to be Native American for decades to
advance her law career
she's got no evidence for the fact
kids didn't go to public school she's
got no evidence for the fact that she
was fired for being pregnant from her
job as a teacher got no evidence for any
of that stuff now I asked myself when
CNN was asking the question why are they
carrying water for her I think the
corporate media generally would prefer
Elizabeth Warren to Bernie Sanders I
mean they the media and the Democratic
parties stole the election from him in
2016 so they probably don't want him to
win in 2020 either that's part of it I
said how are they being so flagrant
about it well how are they being so
obvious that they're saying Bernie
Sanders why did you say this Elizabeth a
Miss Elizabeth Warren how did you feel
when he said this how are they being so
so blatant about it and I think it's
because of the me2 movement the whole
idea behind the me2 movement is we have
to believe all women that's the hashtag
right hashtag believe all women women
can never lie men can lie because the
the lying Jean is on the Y chromosome
but women they can't lie even though men
can be women and women can be men and
chromosomes don't matter at all in
biology is nothing but it's very very
confusing in leftist ideology but the
claim of the me2 movement is we have to
believe all women men cannot get due
process if a man and a woman are making
contrasting claims you've got to believe
the woman this is the perfect example to
show why that premise of the me2
movement is so ridiculous Elizabeth
Warren is a liar through and through
repeatedly consistently and she's doing
it now
and Bernie Sanders is a radical and he's
an old coot and he's a communist and he
has terrible ideas he's really not a
liar that's not what defines this
political career so CNN takes Elizabeth
Warren's side it was such journalistic
malpractice they should be utterly
ashamed of themselves one of the top
trends on Twitter nationwide after this
debate specifically because of this
moment was hashtag CNN is trash and then
at the very end you see the Alliance
break up you see I think the final nail
in the coffin mate they avoided bringing
out
this feud between Warren and Bernie then
they bring it up and they both sort of
move on then at the very end it's pretty
clear this relationship is severed we'll
get to that in a second we'll get to the
rest of the debate what it means for
President Trump what it means for 2020
and then we'll get to news that really
matters because this this debate was
just so bad for the party but first I
got to thank our friends over at Ashford
University make this the year you
advance your career by earning your
master's degree get started today at
Ashford University look going back to
school getting your master's degree it
can help you in your career it can help
you in your own intellectual life it can
help you move forward the trouble is
it's very difficult sometimes it's
difficult to find the time it's very
difficult to go somewhere it's very
difficult to be near University
fortunately Ashford University's online
master's degree programs allow you to
learn at your own pace it's convenient
it's flexible you can study wherever
that you are the most comfortable
learning we talk a lot on this show
about how the old university model is
crumbling it's falling apart Ashford
University is leading the way in a new
innovative model you take one course at
a time Ashford University's six-week
long courses allow you to take one
course at a time so you can go at your
own pace and it's easy to enroll the GRE
the GMAT other standardized test scores
are not required to enroll at Ashford
University check it out get ready to
grab new opportunities Ashford is fully
accredited by the W ASC senior college
and university commissions start your
master's degree today enroll at Ashford
dot edu / Knowles kena wles that's
Ashford dot edu / Knowles to start your
master's degree today Ashford dot edu /
Knowles kena wles by the very end of the
debate all the candidates leave we're
also thank you merciful Lord for ending
this debate and Warren walks up to
Bernie Sanders you can see this on the
clip bernie offers his hand extends his
hand to shake it and Elizabeth Warren
doesn't quite shake it and they engage
in a kind of back and forth
they seem to be pretty argumentative and
then Bernie just walks away Bernie it's
like I've had enough of this this is I'm
not taking these lies anymore I mean you
can't see what they're saying but if
you're reading their body language
that's what it would seem to imply so I
think that this alliance or quasi
alliance is over and I think it's over
because she lied about him she did him
wrong and the reason she did him wrong
is because he was rising too fast in the
polls the reason she did him wrong is
the same reason that the Democratic
Party did him wrong in 2016 he was
rising in the polls unexpectedly they
always liked Bernie as a sideshow but
they don't like it when it looks like he
could win the nomination it was a real
real deceitful move a real real betrayal
of her old pal Bernie Sanders and yet
she wasn't the worst person on the stage
people to judge people to judge my least
favorite candidate in the race was
probably the most ridiculous person on
that entire stage last night Pete during
the debate actually managed to invent
two new PC jargony ridiculous leftist
terms the first of which was climate
security the next president is going to
be confronted with national security
challenges different in scope and in
kind from anything we've seen before
not just conventional military
challenges not just stateless terrorism
but cybersecurity challenges climate
security challenges foreign interference
in our elections it's going to take a
view to the future as well as the
readiness to learn from the lessons of
the past and for me those lessons of the
past are personal what did he just say
did anybody get any actual tangible
policy or philosophy from that soup of
words that he just spouted out no it
meant nothing this is the Budaj edge
candidacy his standing there and looking
really earnest like Alfred E Newman and
a necktie and and really serious and
speaking in a really measured way and
very articulate and he went to Harvard
you know and he's a Rhodes Scholar and
he served in the Navy for a time
and he's just a really serious guy and
he doesn't say anything that means
anything and he holds opposite policy
positions from what he held six months
ago and maybe he's going to be the
radical and maybe he's going to be the
moderate depending on how the polls look
but he's really serious and he just
sounds like a presidential candidate the
trouble is the tone of his voice doesn't
have anything underneath a climate
security what could that possibly mean
climate like the climate is going to
come tell us I mean I guess that's the
claim of global warming global warming
alarmists right is that the Sun Monster
is gonna burn us all up and we're gonna
be dead in 12 years but he's not quite
making that claim he's trying to tie
national security to climate change the
reason he's doing that is because Trump
is doing a very good job on national
security so he can't just talk about
national security because when the
candidates talk about national security
the the voters remember huh we're not at
war with North Korea
we drew down troops in Syria Iran
attacked us and we took out their top
military guy in three days and then they
totally backed down huh Trump is doing a
pretty good job of national security why
do I need this guy so they have to bring
it back to climate change this is a
running theme throughout the entire
debate then booed a judge made up
another imaginary term at another point
he referred to a race informed City he
said as mayor of South Bend Indiana
which is a race informed city we blah
blah blah what is a race informed City I
asked a friend of mine this I said what
what is a race informed City and he said
it's where all the black people know who
peed Budaj edges in South Bend and they
don't like him and that would appear to
be the case if you look at the protests
at his town halls maybe that's the kind
of information I don't know why is why
he's bragging about that at a CNN debate
race informed doesn't mean anything it
reminds me of who Leon Castro when they
were all early on in the debate wholly
on Castro my favorite candidate realize
that he was kind of falling away so he
had to up the stakes on the jargon he
didn't have any actual policies to offer
so he just had to heighten the jargon
heighten the rhetoric they every every
candidate at that debate said we
support reproductive freedom and Castro
leans into the microphone he says I
don't just support reproductive freedom
I support reproductive justice I say
okay I don't I don't know what either of
those things mean other than killing
babies but let's assume that they have
some discreet meaning what would be the
difference between reproductive freedom
and reproductive justice nothing you're
just using a different word and
pretending that that's a more powerful
word than the former one justice I I'm
the mayor of a race informed City we
need to pay attention to climate
security like okay whatever that's fine
it brings up an interesting point about
this debate stage the now smaller more
compact completely white if not
translucent debate stage the two most
intelligent people up there are the
worst Warren and Buddha judge those two
are by far the worst people on stage
they're unlikable they're liars their
secret radicals I mean they're you know
in in the the way that they speak when
it's convenient for them they're
betraying their allies they're stabbing
people in the back so I mean they're
really awful awful candidates they're my
least favorite up there Buddha judge is
a Harvard guy he's a Rhodes Scholar he's
got a degree from Oxford Elizabeth
Warren a pen a pen and Harvard Law
Professor and they're the most shameless
liar is the most cynical and the most
radical it reminds me of this book that
we're gonna be doing on my Prager you
show coming up in the next few months
it's a book called intellectuals by Paul
Johnson and Paul Johnson is this British
historian and he writes a book about all
of the intellectuals from jean-jacques
Rousseau all the way up to the present
and he describes the intellectual is the
kind of successor to priests and
prophets and soothsayers right in the
modern era once we got rid of the
priests once we got rid of God you just
had the intellectual and those were the
people that we really revered and
admired and when you look at
intellectuals one thing that you notice
about them is they're all terrible
people
they're cynical they pursue their own
self-interest they put ideas over people
and they put
selves over ideas and ironically they
have the least regard for truth all of
them jean-paul sartre Berthold Brecht
Rousseau Shelley all of these people
that we would consider the great
intellectuals of the modern era they
were so cynical I mean they would just
defend awful regimes when it was
politically convenient they would deny
truths that they had previously espoused
when those truths became inconvenient
and it's the same with with Warren and
Budaj the nearest thing to a reasonable
candidate on that stage was amy
klobuchar which isn't saying very much
it's damning with faint praise but it's
true she was the closest thing to a
reasonable candidate she's just such an
awful retail politician she's so
cringe-inducing the way she speaks is so
lame that she's not gonna go very far
and Joe Biden who's the putative
frontrunner barely spoke he was not the
star of this debate I forgot he was
there for much of it
terrible debate for Democrats everybody
lost don't take my word for it even Van
Jones who's a major left-wing
commentator on CNN came out after the
debate and he said if this is the best
that the Democrats have then President
Trump is going to get reelected that was
a progressive
to see those two have that level of
vitriol was very dispiriting and I want
to say that tonight for me was
dispiriting Democrats got to do better
what we saw tonight
there was nothing I saw tonight that
would be able to take Donald Trump out
and I want to see a Democrat in the
White House as soon as possible there
was nothing tonight that if you're
looking at this thing you say did any of
these people are prepared for what
Donald Trump is gonna do to us and to
see further division tonight is very
dispiriting he's absolutely right great
analysis man Jones is one of these guys
who he parrots the left-wing line and
the Democratic talking points often but
occasionally he does have an independent
thought and when he does he's very good
he had this on Russia gate you know the
whole Russia collusion narrative he was
asked on a hot mic on a hidden camera
what he thought about the Russian
collusion line about Donald Trump and he
said I'll rush isn't nothing burger we
got to move on to this and that and he
was right I mean it he was right both on
the substance of the matter Trump did
not conspire with Russia but he was
right politically for Democrats as an
adviser to dem
it was stupid for Democrats to harp on
the Russia thing and hurt them in the
long run and they looked like fools when
it turned out it was a hoax so a really
bad night for Democrats and it got even
more radical outside you know in Des
Moines there was a protest of Joe Biden
outside the debate it was a protest by a
group called United We Dream and the
protest was carried on by a group of
illegal aliens who were upset that well
Joe Biden was vice President Barack
Obama deported some illegal aliens they
they were using crazy hysterical
language they said that Obama had
concentration camps to detain illegal
aliens they said we cannot forget under
the Obama and Biden administration this
mass deportation machine was created
machine mass deportation machine no do
you know when the deportation machine
was created when the United States
ratified its immigration laws because
illegal aliens have no right to be in
this country and it's so outrageous that
people who are in this country illegally
don't just kiss the ground and say thank
you thank you you wonderful generous
country for letting me in how wonderful
you are
I thank you so much for not deporting me
I love this country I love freedom let's
make America great again they don't do
that at least this group does not do
that they go out and complain that
there's the threat of deportation that
there is the threat that the government
might enforce the law but probably won't
how backwards is that how crazy has our
political system gotten that foreign
nationals who were in this country
illegally who we are choosing not to
deport for some reason feel empowered to
stand outside expose themselves expose
their crime and complain that we're even
threatening to enforce the law
absolutely outrageous and the majority
of American people know this the
majority of Hispanic voters I suspect
you know this because right most
Hispanic vote the Democratic Party wants
to pretend that Hispanic voters love
illegal immigration
and yet poll after poll after poll shows
this is not true
why because legal Hispanic immigrants
hate that people are cutting the line
why did they have to follow the rules
but a group another group of people
didn't have to if if Bernie Sanders or
any of these Democratic candidates came
out there and said hey all those illegal
aliens that are outside all those people
who are flagrantly violating our laws
some very precious laws to us and
complaining about the fact that we might
even have laws they're all arrested
they're all getting deported if one of
those candidates did that it might kill
them in the primary but they would have
a much better shot at the general
election immigration is a top issue even
for Democrats and nobody wants amnesty
very few people want amnesty but they
can't because the party has become so
radicalized and Biden wants to play it
very safe because Biden is back on top
in one in a new poll there was a
previous poll that came out last week
that showed that Bernie Sanders is on
top in Iowa now there's a new poll that
shows Biden's on top and Biden's whole
strategy here is the Romney 2020
strategy be nothing stay quiet keep your
mouth shut
get your way to the nomination simply
because the other candidates are not
that good and because you're the next
one up and then probably lose the
general election that's Bert Biden
strategy so far we will see if that pays
off then major a new video from project
very to us showing the radicalism of the
Bernie Sanders campaign and what might
happen at the Democratic convention then
I give some advice to Democrats on an
issue they actually could use if they
wanted to and Vince Vaughn gets canceled
poor Vince Vaughn we will look at the
hypocrisy of Vince Vaughn's cancellation
but first I got to say goodbye to
Facebook in YouTube head on over to Daly
wired.com what do you get me that should
be enough isn't that enough for you you
get me you get the andrew pleavin show
the ben shapiro show the Matt Walsh show
you get test questions in the mailbag
coming up tomorrow so get your questions
in you get another Kingdom the final
season we just recorded the final
episode it's really really moving stuff
I can say this because I didn't write a
word of it I just have to read what
Andrew Clavin wrote it's really really
moving and important obviously for
conservatives to be out there
in the culture and you get the leftist
here's tumblr you need that for every
single democratic debate you're
definitely gonna need it on Iowa caucus
night because that's gonna be the first
big test of all of these campaigns head
on over to Daley a wire comm we'll be
right back with a lot more
how did Biden get back on top in Iowa
we're 20 days away from the Iowa
caucuses and according to a new Monmouth
University poll those polls are usually
pretty good Biden is ahead he's got 24
percent that's up five points from the
same poll in November Bernie is in
second at 18% Budaj edge is almost tied
with him at 17 percent Warren is the
lowest of those four but still pretty
close with 15 percent this is different
than the the Des Moines Register CNN
Mediacom poll just a few days ago which
showed that Bernie was on top how could
Biden who is a really awful candidate
has no energy constantly contradicts
himself says random things about his leg
hair and and corn pop I mean how on
earth is that guy on top in this poll
well the reason is the alternative
Bernie Sanders is too radical and James
O'Keefe over a project married to us
just showed that recently I mean Bernie
Sanders showed it himself last night
last night at the debate in Des Moines
Bernie Sanders admitted that he's going
to raise taxes on everybody on virtually
everybody not just the millionaires and
the billionaires he's gonna raise taxes
on everybody who makes more than 29
thousand dollars a year on the Medicare
for all one of the provisions we have to
pay for it is a 4% tax on income
exempting the first twenty nine thousand
dollars so the average family in America
that today makes sixty thousand dollars
would pay twelve hundred dollars a year
okay Bernie Sanders again give him
credit where credit is due at least he's
honest he's saying everybody who makes
more than twenty nine thousand dollars a
year which is what everybody with a
full-time job every button virtually
everybody in this country is gonna have
their taxes hiked four percent by the
way if you're making thirty thousand
dollars a year four percent is a lot of
money if Europe I mean it it hurts
people who are on the lower end of the
income scale more than it hurts people
on the higher end even though the people
on the higher end obviously are gonna
pay more money in hard
dollar terms that's a lot of money and
he's saying look we're gonna raise your
taxes yeah of course we're gonna raise
and it was better than Elizabeth Warren
who says I'm just gonna take two cents
from people who have 50 million dollars
wait two cents you mean two percent and
not on their income you're gonna take
two percent of their actual wealth so
you're just gonna go in and what make
them liquidate their assets you're gonna
take the shirt off their back that said
Elizabeth Warren hurt in her lying
characteristic way bernie is being
honest with you but he's being honest in
a way that's simply too radical for even
democratic voters I think then Project
Veritas caught up with Kyle Urich one of
the field organizers for the Bernie
Sanders campaign he took the radicalism
even further now we know that Bernie
Sanders has always had this bizarre
fascination with in love of Soviet
Russia Bernie Sanders had his honeymoon
in Soviet Russia communist oppressive
Russia he was filmed there with his
shirt off and vodka in his hand singing
communist folk songs with the Russkies
and that appears to have trickled down
to the rest of his campaign Kyle Urich
this field organizer was caught on
camera explaining how we are going to
need to be ready for the Democratic
convention because if they don't give
this to Bernie if they steal it from him
you're gonna see violence you're gonna
see craziness you are gonna see
something that makes 1968 look like a
walk in the park they are going to fight
it out at the convention here is
the cops being f and beaten what's what
I love is he doesn't even know his own
history so he thought it was 1978 that
was the crazy convention instead of 68
but that's fine that's sort of what I
would expect they get even more radical
so the project Veritas journalist asks a
field organizer for Bernie Sanders about
his education policy and the question
that the journalist asks is do you think
that some of these maggot be re-educated
I mean should these people be how should
we bring them over to our side here's
the Sanders campaign in Nazi Germany
after the Nazi Party there was a ton of
the populace that was not to fight like
Germany had to spend billions of dollars
we educate people to not be an athlete
like I'm probably gonna have to do the
same thing here that's kind of what
Bernie cycle for education for everybody
because we're gonna have teaching that
there it is there it is an admission
from the Sanders campaign about their
education policy which is exactly what I
and many others have been saying for
months the whole point of free education
whole point of government-run education
in college and graduate school even is
to indoctrinate a whole generation of
people in their ideology because they
believe that America's Nazis right not
safai and so what they need to do is
reeducate us to be communists I guess or
socialists that's the point of it
free education is a terrible terrible
idea free higher education because
they're not they're not going to be
teaching you Dostoyevsky okay they're
not going to be teaching you the Iliad
and the Odyssey and the ania they're not
to be teaching you Latin and ancient
Greek alright they're not going to be
teaching you classical education they're
going to be teaching you radical leftist
ideology and you and I are going to be
on the hook to pay for it this is why
Democrats have nothing and this is why
they have to keep going back to global
warming Elizabeth Warren kept going back
Bernie Sanders to all of them kept going
back to global warming again and again
last night here's Warren understand this
we have known about this climate crisis
for decades back in the 1990s we were
calling it global warming but we knew
what it was yes we knew about it in the
90s we were calling a global warming in
the 70s you were calling it global
cooling do you remember that and then
after five decades of this crisis
everything is completely fine
crisis we've been in a crisis for five
decades how long does a crisis need to
go on without anything happening before
you realize it's not a crisis but it's
50 years enough I think that probably
should be enough they all keep going
back to global warming because all of
the real political issues show that
Trump is doing a good job right if they
talked about the economy they would say
huh no it's not not really much these
Democratic candidates can offer because
the economy is going gangbusters hitting
record highs if the candidates start
talking about unemployment they would
say huh
Trump has given us record low
unemployment across demographics
probably don't need these Democratic
candidates if they talk about national
security they say huh Donald Trump just
killed the two most prolific terrorists
in the world and re-established
deterrence probably don't need these
Democratic candidates they talk about
anything the jobs coming back the wages
rising for the first time in ten years
anything it shows that the Democratic
candidates are superfluous and and
frankly dangerous so they have to go
back to the imaginary issue of the Sun
monster there is one exception here
there is one issue that the Democrats
could seize on they could easily exploit
that Trump has failed on that they could
try to make a good case on that he's a
real political issue that could maybe
convince voters that issue is federal
spending the federal government spent a
record amount of money in the first
three months of the fiscal year they
spent one I gotta count the
Xero's million billion one point one six
three trillion dollars in the first
three months of the fiscal year 2020 so
that's October through December that's
according to the monthly Treasury
statement that's too much money way too
much money
conservatives are supposed to conserve
we're supposed to be fiscally
responsible and we're not now am I
really that concerned about that right
now I'm not because we're getting so
many even more important wins all right
we're getting wins on the judiciary
we're getting wins in the economy so
there's a lot of growth we're getting
wins on trade we're getting wins on
national security so I'm I'm not going
to let the perfect get in the way of the
good and say I oppose Donald Trump cuz
he's spending as much money as Democrats
do or maybe a little bit more however
this is a big issue all right it's the
it's a legitimate weakness of the Trump
administration and Democrats should
exploit it if they want to have a real
issue to run it but they can't exploit
it because every one of those candidates
every single one wants to make the
spending issue worse all of them they
they've endorsed the green new deal
right many of them co-sponsored it and
that's a 93 trillion dollar plan that
would outlaw all of American energy
virtually and it's not going to help the
spending situation Elizabeth Warren's
health care plan cost fifty two trillion
dollars and that's not going to help the
fiscal situation so they can't exploit
the one good issue they've got and
because they can't exploit it they move
on to impeachment they're now moving
remember they impeach the president you
might have forgotten because it was
nothing then they let that stay for a
month because they knew that the minute
they delivered the impeachment to the
Senate the Senate would acquit him and
then it's over and Pelosi loses all her
leverage so they've now decided they got
to go back to impeachment why cuz
they're candidates for president are
terrible they've got no good issues and
Trump just won World War three they said
that he caused World War three I didn't
say that that was their their term and
then he won it within like two days
without any American casualties so now
they got to go back to impeachment
they've sent the articles of impeachment
against the president their rather
they're set to vote on that today so
unless something crazy goes wrong
they'll vote on that today then it'll go
up to the Senate meanwhile in the House
of Representatives Democrats can't even
get it together to vote on a
resolution condemning the Iranian
mullahs and expressing support of the
Iranian people Kevin McCarthy the the
Minority Leader of the house had a
resolution doing just that saying the
mullahs are awful they shouldn't have
attacked us we don't like them and we
support the people who are rising up and
it failed by a vote of 226 to 191
Democrats cannot bring themselves to
vote for a resolution condemning the
government of Iran for killing 1,500
Iranian citizens protesting their
government they can't vote for a
resolution condemning the Iranian
government for shooting down a Ukrainian
passenger aircraft that killed 176
people they can't do that because
because Trump did the good stuff and if
Trump did it they have to oppose him
that's a very very tight corner that
they've boxed themselves into and you
see it at every level in the house the
local level at the presidential level
really tough stuff and then in the
popular culture in the popular culture
Vince Vaughn was trending top of Twitter
all day yesterday a little bit the day
before because he had the audacity to
shake hands with the President of the
United States they were at that football
game the college football game the other
night and they were sitting there and
they had a little conversation and then
they shook hands and then Vince Vaughn
was the top trend and this was
considered a scandal this was considered
controversial it's not a fake scandal
ginned up on the right this was
considered truly scandalous ABC CBS the
whole mainstream media we're covering
this as though it were some big deal
that an actor shook hands with the
President of the United States let's put
that in perspective last week at the
Golden Globes the actress Michelle
Williams bragged about killing her child
for fame and fortune and Hollywood
applauded her she said in order to have
this glamorous glitzy career that I have
in Hollywood I had to murder my child
and I'm really glad that I was able to
do that to kill my child
Hollywood applauded her so brave so
wonderful the mainstream media
not a peep how brave she wants how
important that speech was yes you go you
go girl I'm woman hear me roar then
Vince Vaughn and actor shakes hands with
the President of the United States
that's a scandal that's a pretty messed
up culture that we're in the majority of
people don't consider it fine to kill
your child but terrible to shake hands
with the president but I bet the
majority of mainstream media journalists
do as you see in the headlines speaking
of that football game I have to get to a
story that's very important it's a story
that has been looked over after the LSU
game some reporters went into the LSU
locker room to interview some of the
players and the players were so excited
they won the game
and they were smoking cigars they
weren't even popping bottles of
champagne as you would expect they would
just smoking cigars the reporters were
furious this one reporter from ESPN
Heather Denish tweeted out it was so
unbelievably smoky in the LSU locker
room from the players smoking cigars I
can taste it and know I didn't have one
it was suffocating and it actually was
very rude of those players not to offer
Heather a cigar they should have offered
her one come on guys chivalry is still
around but what a culture we're living
in that these players big biggest day of
their professional lives or their
scholastic lives even though it'll go on
to their professional lives they're not
allowed to have a cigar in their locker
room because because female reporters in
particular want to go into the men's
locker room and interview them and they
don't want to be around smoke my body my
choice ladies it's very important you
need to be able to celebrate things and
this puritanical culture that we're
getting into when it comes to harmless
things like the occasional stogie is
ridiculous
it reminds us of this Maxim everybody's
got to serve somebody everybody has got
to serve somebody and so we have a
permissive society right now right we
treat sex as though it's nothing it's
sort of like a handshake hook up with
whoever you want we treat recreational
drugs no big deal do it that's fine we
treat we treat everything real ooh
see goosey and yet you do need structure
you do need order you do control so
every time we loosen up some law on
drugs we tighten up some law on speech
every time we loosen up some some social
morei about sex we tighten one up about
cigars because there must be some kind
of control there always will be and I
got to tell you looking around the
culture at this crazy sexual decadence
drug decadence a culture of selfishness
the stogies are looking pretty good
they're pretty much a harmless little
vice I don't even know if they are a
vice but in so much as they are as they
are they're a good vice to have nobody's
ever died from smoking one cigar people
have died from drinking one night people
have died from doing drugs one night
people have died let let people have a
little bit of fun let people have a
lesser vice or they're going to go and
have a tougher one but of course the the
leftist permissive society they know
they don't want the tobacco they want
the harder drugs they don't want sort of
sexual difference to be celebrated in
the locker rooms they want total control
over sex even about redefining sex
itself
men can be women women can be men that's
not that's not permissive it's just they
want the the strictures in place they
want the restraint in in other places
and this actually speaks to this trend
that's going on Yahoo News just
published it yesterday was from AFP but
it's that they're acknowledging a trend
that's been going on in the cities for a
long time the headline was us
speakeasies are back in vogue in the
echo of the Prohibition era century
after the u.s. clamped down on alcohol
and ushered in the prohibition-era
speakeasies are once again popping up
behind hidden doors luring in revelers
seeking fancy cocktails with an illness
at 1920's 5 this has been going on for a
really long time now at the probably 7-8
years in New York and LA DC but now it's
popping up in even smaller towns I go to
a lot of small towns around the country
to give college lectures and I see this
a lot speakeasies now they're not really
speakeasies because alcohol is legal but
they have the speaking
vibe you need a password they serve old
cocktails why are they popping up for
two reasons we long for a time gone by
we don't we don't really we realized
something's wrong about the current era
we're living in and we want to regain
something from the past now nostalgia is
history after a few drinks and past
wasn't all that glamorous but we
recognize there's something from our
tradition we want to get back and we
don't totally love this era the other
reason that specifically the Prohibition
era is coming back in the bar scene is
because we're living through a very
prohibitive time in our culture where
some kids who just want a big football
game can't even smoke a cigar in their
own locker room because the reporters
are coughing because the reporters don't
like the smell of smoke you're not
allowed to say this you're not allowed
to do that
you can't go here you can't go there
every romantic encounter requires you to
get a notarized consent form we're
living in a very prohibitive error and
people are recognizing this and I think
that's that's the underlying cultural
reason why the speakeasies are cropping
back up beyond the fancy drinks and
nostalgia for the past before we go I've
just got to make fun of Mike Bloomberg
Mike Bloomberg posted this really dumb
tweet the other day from his campaign
account and the tweet said it was him
standing in front of a table with some
brisket on it and it said find find a
man who looks at you the way Mike
Bloomberg looks at ribs which was creepy
because there were no ribs in the
picture other than human ribs the guy
who posted the picture didn't know what
brisket was and apparently don't know
what ribs were it was just kind of lame
it was like a like cringy candidate
trying to seem cool and hip and and
young and and me me you know internet e
so during the debate last night where
Bloomberg was not invited he posted a
bunch of these they were so sad there's
a picture of a plate of meatballs and
one of them kind of had Mike Bloomberg
face in it and it said test your
political knowledge spot the meatball
that looks like Mike ha
that's not that's not how memes are
another one through Bloomberg
philanthropies mike has directed more
than 50 million dollars to combat
Meatloaf's views on climate change am i
right hashtag bloomberg facts where
another one what is the best part of the
body to get a Bloomberg 2020 tattoo yeah
you kids like tattoos right hello fellow
kids how you doing another one there was
a picture of these bald eagles which
eagle looks more disgusted with Donald
Trump huh ha kids and final this was the
weirdest one they'd ended up deleting
him when choosing your candidates
remember Mike can fit 9 D batteries in
his mouth at one time the hell does that
mean
yikes then they deleted that one I say
this to make fun of my klumberg I also
say this to make a point about the
candidates
you can't force authenticity
you can't force likability you can't
force electability and you can't out
Trump Trump they're all trying to out
Trump Trump in their rhetoric and their
tweets and their social media strategy
you can't voters can sniff out a fraud
they can sniff out lies they can sniff
out deception they've done it with all
of the candidates so far up there if
those candidates on stage are the best
that they've got as Van Jones said the
election held today Trump would win no
question if the candidates waiting in
the wings like Mike Bloomberg or somehow
the best they've got they're better than
the ones on stage
Trump's getting reelected I mean they
these candidates even even the backbench
even the ones who maybe they come into
the next debate because these these
current crop are failing they just don't
have it they're just not ready for
primetime very good news for President
Trump and conservatives very bad news
for the Democratic Party in the prime
time of their political careers and in
the prime time of that terrible terrible
debate last night that's our show get
your mailbag questions in for tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Moses the
Michael Nolt show see them
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
Andrew clip
[Music]